welcome back we're about to shine a
light on something that not many people
know about it actually could have an
impact on your family and even some
cases it could save your child's life
um and that is preserving your newborns
umbilical cord Blood and Tissue stem
cells
um I actually did this myself when I was
in the hospital giving birth to my first
daughter I learned from the doctors what
the benefits could be and I made the
choice right then and there and then did
it for my second daughter Frankie and we
teamed up with cord blood registry to
share its impact well this family chose
to store their baby's newborn stem cells
with cord blood registry and it changed
their lives forever
one of the best Days of Our Lives was
when we brought Thomson home from the
hospital to meet his big brother Khan
but our lives changed one week later
when our pediatrician calls to tell us
that's the last one had skid skid stands
for severe combined immune deficiency
which basically means he was born
without an immune system and we were
thinking through our options and she
mentioned she asked me oh is this
something we can maybe use the cord
blood for and I was like oh man I called
the immunologist right away and I asked
him is this something we can use for
sauce and he said yes absolutely this is
literally the reason you save that when
the doctors told us that Von's poor
blood was a match for his brother we
took a collective big sigh of relief
choosing the savon's cord blood with CBR
ended up being the best decision we
could have ever made because it
essentially gave Sassoon a chance it
gave us our second boy back with CBR our
family's been saved and our boys now
have an unbreakable Bond
joining us to discuss word blood
registry as spokesperson Dr Christine
Sterling it is so nice to talk to you
nice to be here thank you I'm so excited
because when I was told what the
possibilities were in the hospital with
my first daughter Olive I signed up for
it yeah but explain what newborn stem
cells are what are the benefits and why
would an expecting family save them the
umbilical cord is made up of tissue and
contains blood both of which are rich
sources of stem cells with the potential
to act like our body's own personal
repair kits so Sassoon needed immune
cells cells to protect him from viruses
and bacteria and because his brother was
a genetic match doctors were able to
transplant the stem cells from his
brother's cord blood into him curing his
disease what steps should a family take
if they're considering saving their
newborn stem cells you would enroll with
Cord Blood registry either online or via
the phone CBR is the largest family
newborn stem cell preservation company
and the number one most recommended by
OB gyns so once you enroll a kit is
delivered to your house now the critical
thing is you have to bring that kit with
you to the hospital once you're at the
hospital you hand it over to your health
care team and we collect the cord blood
and the cord tissue it's delivered to
Tucson Arizona with cord blood registry
will process freeze and store your
newborn stem cells okay good what
medical conditions can potentially be
treated with the newborn stem cells
newborn stem cells are currently being
used for transplants for certain blood
disorders like sickle cell disease and
certain cancers like acute lymphocytic
leukemia there are over 80 known
conditions that can be treated with
transplants of newborn stem cells and
there are over 500 clinical studies that
have been initiated looking at the uses
of newborn stem cells from cord blood
and cord tissue in regenerative medicine
I was so glad that I was given an option
and it's yours to take or not but when
you hear about something you can put in
a bank to save you on another day I
immediately signed up both my daughters
for it so thank you for enlightening us
with this yeah
[Music]
watching on CBR visit cordblood.com
thank you guys we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you